louder with Crowder studios protected
exclusively by Walter and hopper
[Applause]
are you ready I can't hear you the kids
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
that's called the creepy man at Gerald's
actual wedding he danced like this
nobody locked eyes he looked across the
floor and he was mad because I think
Tommy you know mocking him naturally to
my wife not you just was doing this but
he did this like a little bit more
bigger give it a pot hey we have
dancringe on the show my half-asian
lawyer bill Richman is here in third
chair thank you very much baby I know
who kept you up all night yes he did you
can still carry this show with it's true
one hand tied behind its back mainly
because he has very short arms
quarterblack he runs your foot past boom
what's the won't get the sell product
and I don't question the date we're
gonna have Dan Crenshaw and we'll be
talking about the recent sort of deep
platforming apocalypse I guess oh my god
we talked about the recent transgender
vice powerlifting video but so question
for you question is still it has the
recent D platform that's occurred to a
lot of people on Facebook and Instagram
has it been jarring or do you like me
worried that it might just become white
noise now and how close are anymore
doing to deleting I see what you did
there you can do it because you're
yellow
ish are you close to deleting your
social media accounts and which platform
do you think is most likely to go first
given the increasing number of emails
about that yeah Facebook that's to go
down and mothers on Facebook really has
gotten so old remember you have a
college dress full of boomers who's that
myspace arted like MySpace was for hoops
xanga was for Asians and Facebook was
for elite college students there you go
that's a if you've lost your way
Facebook you need to be yourself when my
mom's on Facebook you know it's gotten
old when you're on Facebook you know
it's got no I'm starting us off today
Jessica Shan do I pronounce that
correctly the name Ava Duvernay I don't
even know who she is sure anyways the
chastised gameofthrones see what I did
there for racial insensitivity
this comes from the inside both
influential women of Hollywood tweeted
following Sunday's episode in which the
show's only named character who was a
woman of color was killed spoiler alert
I should have said that fat yeah yeah
that I should note they weren't really
upset about the
killing as much as they thought it was
racially insensitive the way it was
performed I could see how it registers a
little tone deaf I get it a little
insensitive there okay so so the the
puck used to be in this zone right all
right we want women in things okay we
need gay people and things now we need
people of color and things now we need
gay people of color that are women in
things and now they must survive until
the end Y episode no one was complaining
about the white guys it's a miracle that
she made it this far I'm not really sure
that the last episode it's gonna be
someone traveling in a DeLorean nuking
the whole page no one's going to make it
at the ending I don't understand here
why are you pissed
the recent thing with Captain Marvel
about how brie Larson was saying well
you know we wouldn't be inclusive and
have women yeah and then all of a sudden
it turned into well actually brie Larson
you shouldn't be diverse than you should
play this role and it's like whatever
and I mean soon you have women of color
it's a better transgender that have arms
and then you need the ones without the
arms and without the fingers I mean like
what I mean we're never they just think
they're pleasing crocodile's those few
it's like piranha night 3d with you know
chicks with us next we have is to see
then this transy and I'm saying that
because yeah since it ones being deep
platformed we can get around it by a
fancy make it a thing ah this trans he's
making the case at Venezuela we just saw
this video and I promise you it's real
Venezuela more democratic better off in
the United States here's a clip there is
so much to eat
in the united states from what they've
done in venezuela yes
the transient question at lavender and
red on the twitter biography refers to
him/her selves yourself as a transgender
autistic revolutionary I thought autism
meant you were a genius what does what
does autism even mean anymore it's
really just evening like it's become an
incredibly broad umbrella yeah yeah
perfect I see this program has commenced
as planned and they have yet to notice
me but you must understand that for me
the shadows are not a place from which
to emerge but a place in which to dwell
for days in the shadows that I can
accomplish my greatest work and with
time exert my greatest authority so ed
what artistic when I was a kid then in
grade school yeah yeah we had one us he
was eight he was Chinese his name was
with the bleep it Christ I'll say wait
Fung does that help me it hurts either
and I see that there's a range from
genius virtuoso to actually mentally
returning this kitten comments they're
talking about comic books right and I
would get in trouble this is a true
story so we were in the middle of our
final exam you know close to summer and
we're doing a math exam and Witten gets
out from his desk with incredible
purpose by the way from a desk stands up
in the middle of the exam about having a
heart attack laughing like I just erekle
and they kicked me out how do you kick
me out for this do you think he came out
as well our move like that best with
video games and I knew was doing the
Shang soon holding a glowing head yeah I
knew it they're just sitting there
laughing and they kicked me out
this kid also by I've told the story
puncher in the balls it's the one time I
call in grade school we were doing the
learning the Fosbury flop or you don't
line up and run and jump over the the
high the high jump bar Fosbury flop is
where you jump back and fall on your
back right
so we'd have two lines in gym class I
remember name was mr. bono
called mr. boehner because he loved and
still thought of it I'm standing in line
and I realized that this this one kid
who's autistic they just call him
autistic that's all we knew Brian yeah
he doesn't realize that were lining up
to wait our turn and run and jump over
the mat he just jumps and right on his
shoulders right in the hardwood floor
and start yeah be okay and he just
started repeating kick your ass kick
your ass and punch me in the balls as
hard as he could that's good good this
is a true story
and now you just have some strange very
smart and you know has to wear earplugs
when he sleeps and we call them autistic
does someone know where's the line where
is the genuinely it's gotten broad there
are lines it's just some folks choose to
ignore them and exploit the labels for
whatever they wanna do I mean they take
something that is scientific and
legitimate and certainly the boundaries
are you know they have to be adjusted at
times as more information comes there's
a different variance of different things
but to be able to say wherever you want
and whatever you it whatever you think
you are is just gonna somehow be on the
continuum of the spectrum just doesn't
make it it makes me get a lawyer Jesse
I'm out of him wherever you is on the
continuum relate to the spectrum rap
which really relates to the panel you
know how it is though right you know
understand you do not understand the
past tense of what I am laying down
finally it must be hard to define
honestly like autistic in Asian because
some of those kids they're very socially
awkward and they're very good at dance
yeah I would just say well autistic look
he just has a Chinese mom sorry yeah
sure could have fooled me all day and
banned for Gabbana social media in 2020
news Pete but gig says that this week he
said if God belonged to a political
party it wouldn't be the Republican
comes from Business Insider of course
this was immediately after saying it's
important that we stop seeing religion
uses a kind of cudgel perfect word for
him to use so God would not be a
Republican when reached for comment
however a representative Satan said he
was away on business so that was pretty
much okay when reach later for comment
he was too busy having sex with Pete but
gig
I think this is a little bit odd right
he claims to be what is an Orthodox it's
not Orthodox an Orthodox sorry it's a
wrong word sorry he claims to be a
Christian and then he questions Mike
Pence's belief in Scripture he says
maybe Mike Pence doesn't believe in
Scripture now anymore I'm like you sir
would you like to talk about
homosexuality and the potential verses
that could be in the Bible that effect
that you're telling me that because
you've got a bad guy your words bad guy
in office that Mike Pence doesn't
believe the Bible anymore and your
lifestyle probably doesn't oh it's
business alien stop using religion to
divide because you clearly have not read
the Bible and don't know anything this
week no that's not the point they say
don't use it to divide and then you
don't know any yes yes I know is it lost
tonight is it lost joke okay all right
Gerald all right okay
the week's trivia contest one about Sam
more at Sam tastic 300 for correctly
identifying the plus-size model test
holidays blood type good job was pudding
so you'll be getting a free t-shirt and
Jean a scraping of half-asian level rich
mastery in the mail still fun joy though
and the DNA script so we're going to
talk about and I was super glad that
half-asian where bill Richman was here
and I can never tell you know he has a
newborn if he's tired if it's just Asian
face because you don't you never think
imagine you're I not know they're just
there all the time very tight you look
like you've always slept well but then
you also look like you're always just a
little bit irritated yeah no that's
actually that's my life
probably works for you the lawyer Horne
right yeah my features have hardened I
just wanted to make a few seconds that's
how bad I felt that's how badly I felt
when you just earlier stepped on a reap
restating my position that's that's your
boo that's my position - all right okay
I hope your new wife husband is watching
okay so over the past week we've seen
another purge obviously of cannot only
we've seen this of conservatives but we
have seen rejoicing from the left I'm
delighted to see this they are taking
out the trash these awful people
mitigating encouraging violence
sanctioning violence look you have no
right to speak on someone else's
platform let my low
let's go to geo cities or my face is
something he can't go on Facebook
Facebook and I think I agree a lot means
like an anti-semitic or tune it's a
company right we don't like regulation
then it should regulate itself I feel
like that first guy was talking mr.
honey la no Mars watching it like I mean
come on it's like la we should just do
this program like cable news it would be
so much easier to be no prep hey what do
you think sir outrage and I'm sounding
slightly like Woody Allen crust with the
Nutty Professor from The Simpsons
Milo you napple Apple Apple Asst I want
to make sure that I clear about this and
Bill will obviously help clarify this
this is not a this is not a freedom of
speech issue okay so before people yell
private company I want you to hear what
we're about to talk what we're about to
discuss and let's go over kind of the
new rules as to what is and isn't
allowed yeah you're about to say some in
there no no that I was agreeing I think
it's an incredibly important to set the
tone because we're not making that
argument and a lot that's what everybody
is going to say is right you're making a
free speech argument in the wrong case
so just as important as kind of
understanding why and which
conservatives are banned is looking at
the behavior that's routinely accepted
from the left so there have been clear
terms of service violations from the
left things I like doc saying things
like threatening people things like
inciting people to violence with no
consequences I wouldn't be really clear
I don't want any preferential treatment
I don't think any Kyle I do think some
conservatives do I love to get to that
in a second yeah I just want to know the
rules and I think that's an important
distinction that people need to make
this either dishonest business practices
or not knowing where they line up and
not applying the law equally well I
think through the even just the point in
our own experience has been the company
is often unclear left hand right hand
about what the rules are right even day
to day even your own kind of rules
handling the same videos being handled
differently in different times by
different people raised that there's a
level of subjectivity that means that
when the company is out there selling
its platform as a in reality it's be and
that is when you get to the heart of a
fraud that that they're using to build a
business platform on I mean people
choose to use the platforms and spend
money on those platforms and give their
data valuable data do these companies
thinking that they're getting something
that they're really not right yeah
there's there's an exchange of services
here like you said that data the data is
one of the big things that drives the
revenue obviously of any of these
companies right having access to
consumers and understand
their habits being able to crunch that
data you've given your part and now
they're saying no you can't be on this
platform anymore because the rules that
we can't even tell you how do we enforce
we clearly don't honor their own rules
so just in case you think that you think
I'm making some democratic state
representative we'll talk with Dan
Crenshaw about this in a second Brian
Sims you guys see this where he
videotaped himself I don't know a
videotape as a term anymore people just
realized that if we were lucky we'd
8-track ourselves and said that a
mixtape so he videotapes itself he sells
feed himself which sounds redundant
harass and young girls and old ladies
praying outside of abortion clinics and
offered money to anyone who would Doc's
them lest you think I'm making it up hi
everyone representative Brian Sims here
and I am outside the Planned Parenthood
at southeastern Pennsylvania
oh no they're leaving now a bunch of
pseudo Christian protesters who don't
need to look really clear an elected
official reason money to anyone who
would Doc's pro-life prayer volunteers
you could live the rest of your life
with singular purpose and unbelievable
focus in an attempt to and and still not
accomplish anything that should do it
volunteer book arrives oh my gosh pseudo
Christians you're a pseudo Christian
because you're a my point of view that's
also Alexander Cortes she was talking
with a car that's was talking about that
sweet she says billions of people don't
know anything about women's bodies
talking with the Georgia bill say well
holla something we're learning about
women's bodies alright after six weeks
the reason it's called a heartbeat bill
because you're stopping the heartbeat
whose heartbeat speech is that is I can
I not understand that because I'm a man
or do I actually just understand you're
the party of science that if you have
two hearts you are a medical marvel
someone get Ben car
and by that logic men should only be
able to operate on men and women on
women because you can't possibly
understand the female body if you're a
man so why would you dare try to operate
on him
also plumbers yeah he took this guy by
the way this is what's also really
egregious here is he took the video he's
dreamed it didn't yeah yeah videotape
himself he streamed on a periscope
when my in my day a periscope was when
you took some milk cartons this guy
obviously feared no consequences that's
what bothers me
doxing by the way in targeted harassment
expressly outlined as banned abullah
fences yeah and Twitter's terms of
strategy is pretty clear and they should
be this isn't an isolated incident
remember Peter Fonda the actor he calls
for Baron Trump to be abducted and raped
by pedophiles lest you think I'm
exaggerating again and I know my
half-asian we're bill Lishman gets he
gets a little uncomfortable you doesn't
going too far these this is a quote
Peter for Easy Rider was fun are you
ready yes yeah okay
we should rip Baron Trump from his
mother's arms and put him in a cage with
pedophiles and see if mother will stand
up against the giant ass she is married
to now I know at first glance that seems
pretty cut and dry I don't know what to
believe anymore
he's still up on Twitter by the way
right now no punishment but he
apologized but I'm sorry too late go
upstairs
I don't care there's literally hundreds
of examples the the rest of the show the
rest of this next week's shows could all
be the examples of this
you haven't Kerry Kathy Griffin every
one of these people have said
reprehensible things no I think it's
important to delineate vital showing a
severed head is different that's not
raised this chai
that's not all she's done though right
but there's so many things that they
have done that that would under under
this the band that just happened would
easily have gotten them kicked off right
this is also them it's important it's
also illegal that's somebody people need
to understand threat actually making a
threat of violence or inciting people to
violence you yeah this whole idea you
can't yell fire in a crowded theater you
actually can yeah if there's a fire in
it if there's not I believe a legal term
is fraud week
refer this as lying yeah right the thing
is if you try to respect the laws they
don't abide by the laws we have people
who sign consent we have people who say
I agree to appear on camera change my
mind and then go to youtube say I don't
want to be on there anymore and u2 makes
us blur it we so first off it's a single
party consent state we're not breaking
the law and we can show you them giving
permission accuse oh we don't care
because I just want to deal with the
problems that is the issue these these
offenses are actually illegal by the way
hit the notification bell actually just
bookmark the channel on YouTube because
notifications may not work join up a lot
of credit complex mug club and of course
you can leave a rating there on iTunes
so let's compare this with what gets a
ban on the right in direct contrast to
leniency given to left is good to have
anything right or wrong so far legally
no I actually was gonna say that the
exact other point would be probably
people would hear the end of the first
comment and say okay so what's your
position that they should be allowed to
say these things if that they shouldn't
be allowed to say anything and the point
being that there's a disparity right the
whole point is yeah people are being
treated differently not because of you
know the certain what they're saying
it's because of the view that is being
espoused by whether it's right or
Jonathan Hoenig was just making the
point that I don't like what they're
saying and so they shouldn't be able to
say it wait what well the whole private
dancing and that's not what we're
talking we'll get all that difference
being publisher and platform that's the
most important point here so I think a
lot of people have missed when they're
calling for Galatian so on Twitter
though before we get there
several the accounts were banned I think
this within the last two weeks
the Acacio accorded the parity account
James Warren suspended the Mogga fobia
account which was very surprising to me
it attract violence against
conservatives it's like it's like a
block parent on video videotaping what's
going on someone videotaping an aunt if
a person punching it'll lay in the
facing hey watch out for that guy on
there you're banned why cuz you upset
the old lady let's try to start getting
drunk she was really upset
exactly and paper-thin reasons were
given for example the the parody account
of contest would clearly fit the
guidelines there's Twitter policy parody
accounts are allowed yeah they it was
clear that it was a broken what I love
writing Twitter said the account was
seen as misleading going a little too
close to the source material I said
look it's not their fault that AOC is
actually that crazy that people were
confused with that account okay it's not
our fault that she actually is that
crazy sorry you're telling me that the
problem is that I say stuff that should
be completely untrue and nobody should
believe it and that they believe it and
that I'm the problem
yeah it's it's her Bernie's thoughts
it's hard for me to tell the difference
yeah sometimes I have to undo the
retweet because i retweeted thinking I'm
dunking on senator Sanders oh it's not
him he really sounded like he was that
mad about Pringles it's sad this person
his voice remarkably yeah and then of
course Facebook and Instagram they they
banned people like Milo innopolis Paul
Joseph Watson which I really don't
understand the Paul Joseph Watson though
that when he get put in that list well
they clearly violated the dangerous
individual to policy you're dangerous
but again the reasons here hardly make
any sense when you're splendid the show
is continuing just as I'd hoped
though many do not know my name nor
recognize my face it is by my gentle and
that the ship is guided
noticed and once that ship has served
its useful purpose
I shall coax it into the rocky shore as
a beautiful siren does and beckoning
from the dark sea so is there a legal
precedent there for dangerous
individuals is that a law no I mean they
they have their own policies right and
those policies sometimes they you know
deign to give us a definition of them
sometimes they don't those definitions
often change it's possible that they
have drawn from some statute but it's
not expressly referenced so no okay the
policy itself does not refer to any
particular law that's when it says
dangerous well what's really dangerous
to me ironically here is that they say
someone like Gavin McGinnis designate a
dangerous individual cat Facebook and
now it's saying that anyone who
associates with these people could also
be a dangerous individual I don't know
how far that necessarily extends
obviously Gavin has been a has been a
colleague right we work together but
then we've had people on this show who
we don't agree with at all is that
considered association the rules are
never clear yeah absolutely they said
something about you know just taking a
picture with Gavin begin as well louis
farrakhan was one of the guys that was
banned on this by the way I would stand
up and fight and say I hate everything
that person says but I feel like they
should be able to say it I'm pretty sure
that presidential candidates presidents
and plenty of people in the Democratic
Party have had pictures with this guy
have a tendency his church have said
under his tutelage and they're still out
there
right this isn't fair at all right one
morgg's I saw Brock Obama with a
Farrakhan is my homeboy t-shirt that's a
fact
pretty sure you bought at Urban
Outfitters but really just tell that
he's not all that original it's a
different form that actually ban any
pictures of anyone even seen wearing our
socialism's for Figg shirt which by the
way can be purchased at letters credit
shop come along with his wonderful nudie
platform this crest t-shirt that's the
crowd impressed I love that one but we
retro actively photoshopped all of those
pictures with the socialism's for fake
shirts to abide by the Twitter Terms of
Service so as you can see always
thinking one step ahead
makes no sense to people listening on
audio now here's one thing to a lot of
people see that they see any right-wing
critique of social media companies as
hypocritical again if you aren't clear
about what your problem is
hey can you regulate some industries
conservatives are like it's not the
government's job to regulate private
business but then as soon as they feel
like they're not getting enough
retweets suddenly it's like we're
launching an investigation we've got a
national life tech companies long live
socialism Bernie I love how that clip
was dead silent until you could actually
hear the applause break carton coming up
know what to do I mean I can't use the
affirmative action Comedy Central higher
but we thought it'd make it easier for
us to play a look we don't want to
nationalize social now and this is my
proposed solution this is really why I
want I want to get bills taken this this
allows all parties to freedom to choose
okay and I think it just needs to be as
simple as a question needs to be
answered officially legally on the
record these social media companies the
court of law they need to decide whether
their platforms or publishers because
those two things are very very different
a publisher something like the New York
Times or even louder with grata or this
channel they can monitor content publish
on their site they can take they have to
take responsibility for if they
published a family information or they
incite violence they can be sued for
that because they're responsible for the
content a platform which would be more
like say a cell phone company they
provide a network they don't monitor
they don't censor your calls okay now
the reason that people have refer to
these social media companies and have
come to know them as platforms is
because they've legally been afforded
some of those rights not granted to a
publisher and what are those some of you
might be asking one's to protect them
from being sued as long as they operate
as a platform so if someone tweets for
example something to fam'ly Tory about
me like I don't know puts on a fake Nazi
sitter can't be sued for that as long as
they're a platform but that means if
they're a platform this is all I
understand that bill is going to trick
me here
they cannot determine which point of
views are allowed disallowed pick sides
you try to determine winners and losers
just based on point of view there's a
difference when a publisher and a
platform and I think that lately they've
been acting in a way they'll put them
firmly in the territory of publisher and
people don't know the rules
bill I will give the analogy to explain
it to the left of when you hear folks on
the right say guns don't kill people
people kill people right it's the person
utilize them kills a little Facebook
okay
yes they do yeah in the back of a pizza
parlor and if joking it's about
I'm joking for people who got really ill
I'm not pushing the gate sorry alright
so so the so the idea is that is the
tool doing it or is it the person
controlling it and if you're not
controlling the tool then the person who
is is the one that's in trouble so it's
the publisher the one who's putting the
message out and the person who is just
the phone line the tool provider the
platform there has to be a protection of
that because otherwise there would be no
financial incentive to be for example
any kind of platform to provide those
kind of tools if a criminal you know
orders a drug deal over a cell phone
does that mean that we should punish the
cell phone companies because they should
be controlling it no and in that same
way the the companies have changed
recently Jack Dorsey actually admitted
surprisingly in an interview that he
found himself to be a public marketplace
of ideas and then was talking about his
determination as a company that they
should be censoring and again censoring
not in the constitutional sense but
censoring in this in the idea of how
they're gonna limit what the ideas are
so they are actively choosing it by
actively choosing they've crossed that
threshold from just a neutral platform
to a publisher who's choosing the
messages they want to put out there and
they should be they should be helping
you do that today should they be called
to testify does there need to be a
hearing my point is I think before we
get to any kind of regulation is give
them the opportunity to answer make them
to declare publisher or a platform in
which case I think we'd be talking about
like public utility laws what would that
be some of it could be within the courts
right so the existing law that's out
there the precedent that's out there
about when you cross from I mean this
isn't an unusual question it's not like
this is the first case that would ever
be heard about what's the difference
between being a publisher or a platform
or that kind of thing
right um but it's actually putting them
to task and the thing is is that people
have asked this question over the years
it's not you know sound like oh just all
of a sudden 2019 people asking this
question right but in the past it's been
different and we can see it's change
it's been in a creative change over the
years where now they are firmly over the
line especially you know platforms like
Twitter and the new policies that are
coming out from platform and you to our
Facebook in YouTube yeah you to that
that are making an eclipse look
different I mean we knew what a year or
two ago when it was open hunting season
and Twitter on you know kids you know
conservative views right now they would
call that's because when you
move the center so far left everything
on the right is far right you know right
which by the way is also very I don't
want you go to your point which is also
very important to conservatives out
there if we if we do this and this this
is I think the route that we should take
again comment let me know that means
that if you're a conservative you're
gonna have to accept these rules for
everybody so don't break the law right
don't don't criminally trespass right in
the videotapes um I'm use that word
again film someone on their private
property and then claim that you're
being but please don't do that because
you can film in a public area in a
single party consistent you cannot go
into someone at home or on their lawn
and film them they're just like you
can't put out there a false meme that
you know to be false to harm somebody
just because you don't like them and
that means conservatives are going to
have to allow Ilhan Omar Farrakhan to
post all the anti-semitic crap they want
by that same token Twitter
you can't allow Hamas to recruit people
so at that point when we say you're a
platform then at least we know okay you
have to at least there has to be some
semblance of abiding by the law for
which all of us can have reasonable
expectations right now there are there's
their rule set and then there's law and
sometimes you you can be obeying one in
breaking the other for example Peter
Fonda hoping that Baron Trump's get
raped raped by pedophiles yeah you would
think oh I don't know that seems like
we're a okay
AOC parody we're a little murky on the
legality at that point yet I just want
to know what the rules are and I think
that's what conservatives need to be
pushing for not locking arms
hand-in-hand with people like Pelosi and
people like Cortes also want sweeping
regulation of these guys yeah and and
the point that he made at Trevor Noah
made that we want like it's because of
retweets and likes and we're not getting
it that that's not the point at all the
point is that you have to have and this
is where it does circle back to a free
speech argument the only reason these
things are coming up is because in the
world not on social media there are free
speech fights going on right now on what
is hate speech is it really even a thing
is it is it is it okay for you to to try
to understand what's in somebody's head
when they commit a crime and it's an
hate crime or what they say and it's
it's hate speech or it's some pseudo
protected group that all of a sudden we
can't say anything bad about them
because they're the cause hate speech is
not an actual thing in the United States
no but people Article II now but hold on
but people are calling it something
right they're saying that's hey
speech you can't say no this is a real
question is it because it because in
Canada and the UK hate speech is an act
it's an actual legal term yes it is an
actionable offense in the United States
hate speech is that I'm not sure if
there are some states or you I mean so
each of the states could have their own
law so there's certainly some states
that probably have that as a definition
I don't know yeah so my point wasn't
that not that it's a law but society is
starting to lean that way and say oh
right this is hate speech you can't say
these things and that's filtering into
these platforms the things that are
happening out in our culture today are
filtering into the platforms and that's
why they're kicking people off like that
it's because there's social pressure
right other people saying that's wrong
that's why it is a First Amendment on
that graph yes and I think it's
important that people do understand the
legality of it and understand the
difference in a platform and a publisher
and by the way I'm like we're we're talk
we'll talk about Bill Bar with Dan
Crenshaw we have to get to him he
probably waiting for us um this it's
he's he's an under no requirement to
speak with more lawyers by the read he
there are no requirement to provide a
completely unrelated report to the
public and or all members of Congress
Congress this is a legally relevant
question here unlike the bar situation
because I know people will accuse the
left in the right nah man you're always
playing politics no no we just want some
clarity we're calling for more
transparency not less I think that's
pretty important because again when you
talk about sweeping national legislation
it's not about Donald Trump right now
again the Mogga hat-wearing people who
just like to troll no there's gonna be
someone else in office after President
Donald Trump so let's try and take some
steps in the right direction allowing
for more freedom not less the good news
here is we can actually take a first
step
low cost requires very little
bureaucratic red tape or any kind of
overall right away it only requires the
truth and require social media companies
to put their money where their mouth is
and if they want to continue to benefit
from the umbrella and the legal
protection of a platform fine or do they
want to remove it edit and censor
content based on point of view like a
publisher this can all start with just
two yes-or-no questions and all that's
needed for the serta revolution really
right now in fairness and transparency
and honesty is to get these big tech
CEOs the owners in the hot seat and all
that's required is to get them to answer
yes or no that's what I think a good
starting point would be all right we do
have to get going to Dan Crenshaw
half-asian to the lawyer but thank you
so we have to go
he's smart too Oh
let's go to the merge shot let's all go
to the merge shot
let's all go to the merge shot by
ourselves some sweaty snazzy clothing
and swag divided louder with crowded
shop calm like this new signature
baseball team for these Ranger panties
for of course the Holy Grail itself mug
club that sound
[Music]
[Applause]
and now for barely legal with Bill
Richmond sponsored by mclubbe for louder
with Crowder I'm half asian lawyer bill
Richmond today's question comes to us
from Ethel in Beaver litt Kentucky who
asks as I have often heard them used
interchangeably I'd like to know what is
the difference between a TR O and an
injunction if there is any difference at
all Ethel great question I'll start at
the top an injunction is one of two
things either a court telling you you
can't do this or affirmative lis saying
you must do this certain actions and
restrictions so the types of injunction
generally and these words in terms kind
of differ depending on what state you're
in you'll have a temporary restraining
order which is that TR o generally only
lasts a finite amount of time in certain
states like Texas it will only last for
two to four weeks in a temporary
injunction you will have in for example
some courts it will last the entirety of
the case so while you're fighting for
your life under a mountain of discovery
a temporary injunction will be in place
finally at the end of a case you may
have a permanent injunction which is a
piece of paper that will control your
life forever
because it's in place now as a bonus one
of the things that you can learn is
about contempt of court that's the
failure to comply with an injunction you
gotta listen to the gavel ethyl you
gotta listen finally I'd like to ask a
question of my own is your name really
Ethel were you born in ninety five year
old with cataracts some advice find your
parents file a permanent injunction this
has been barely legal with Bill Richmond
sponsored by mug club
[Music]
[Music]
okay
[Music]
okay
[Music]
[Music]
you know I've noticed a change in dance
trends it used to be all in the hips now
it's all in the shoulders
yeah there's no there's a lot I mean you
really I mean that is very very white
here I'm certainly african-american
cerium Co what do you prefer Pilate
never told me black a person of color
every Negro is that there's none French
that's the word that what my mother's my
mother gets in so much trouble because
in French the word is similar than Rome
at a man's language just what's in it
she gets in trouble and she's trying to
find the right word in English you know
she can't say it right all right that's
a horrible introduction but my mother is
a french-canadian and she it's true it's
true the word in French is is isn't is
negative in French that is the word and
she would use it mom you can't say that
but I was trying to set the nice but
black is so much more offensive like I'm
like mom it's I don't know what to say
anymore okay no all right our next guest
I'm a huge he's been on here recently
just making waves because first let me
list his qualification yes I don't tell
you guys been making waves of course
he's a United States represent second
District second conditional just the
second congressional district in Texas
two Bronze Star medals former Navy SEAL
Purple Heart went to Harvard after the
military service and and recently was on
the view you can follow him at Dan
Crenshaw TX represent of Crenshaw thank
you for being here sir great to be with
you again Stephen hey I'm glad to have
you you back now right before we went to
air I asked you and you said you have
very strong opinions on this before we
get to the what happened with the view
and Omar and all that stuff is it can
you name me an instance where it would
be appropriate to wear black athletic
socks with shorts I don't think there
ever is well you're wrong so here's the
thing it depends it depends on it
depends on how you're defining black
athletic socks if you're talking about
tube socks then I think you can make a
pretty good argument I'm not so sure why
anyone wears tube socks in the gym okay
because I mean really what is what is
what is the functional value of the tube
sock you have to constantly pull it up
is it looks do you think
looks good is that what your if that's
what you're referring to then I agree
but if you're referring to more ankle
ankle athletic socks like running socks
then I really see the problem with
having black socks I see a huge problem
with it as well as your comments on tube
socks allow me to explain why you did
not walk into the view here sir and I
will defend my position okay tube socks
deadlift - tube socks to reduce friction
on deadlifts that's why all power
lifters use tube socks when they
deadlift because you can scrape your
[ __ ] if you think that's true of course
look at Madison look at auntie Bolton
they old it doesn't help that much but
it does help a little bit that's a
deadlift max tell everybody
4:55 it's not that impressive i it's not
like manny who's very small yeah I'm not
I'm not that's not bad
no I was for me I'm naturally a weak
person I made the eleven hundred total
club with a 315 bench 455 deadlift in a
425 squad for me that was a big deal
Marc repet always made fun of me he
pooped repeatedly for that I did not put
my fantastic my uncle to do that and
then when it comes to athletics you're a
military man so it imagine you respect
efficiency here's the deal
white athletic socks are always
appropriate with shorts there is no
discernible benefit to having black
athletic socks ever so why not just have
the white athletic socks can we just go
back to do you mean tube socks
no I mean any blacks even it was not a
tube sock what's the advantage to a
blind about sandals exactly well that's
a whole tube sock it was three on
sandals will find comfort but what's the
advantage to a black athletic sock
everything tennis shoe a white sock
because you can wear them with shorts
well what can't you wear a black socks
with shorts
you can't know it will respect you all
right no it's not a Canadian game
Canadian it's a it's a man who you still
haven't explained why you need to socks
do deadlifts I just they all do all the
best dead lifters do and so I do it it's
anecdotal but you know I want to feel
like I want to be like Magnuson someday
no it's not listen it's not gonna
protect it if you actually really pull
it back into your shins but it can put
it with a little bit of like the
friction versus back your shins
deadlifts supposed to lean back on those
deadlifts oh yeah we've had more crypto
in here he's given me hell for not
leaning back enough he's I'll i deadlift
more than you so high
that's you and then mark repperton will
tell us that we are all wrong every time
guys like you are an absolute fail this
is you can be right I'll still see you
yeah it's not about since we're talking
about Jim fash and Rilke the thing that
I don't understand is the giant
headphones in the gym like the beep
headphones yeah you mean the bacteria
saucers I called them yep it seems
really hard to like sweat and be very
active and dynamic with those big
headphones so that that's a question I
have for you but it's not hard to wear
them in sweat and be a douche so it
depends on priorities when you go to the
gym
say that about people they're all good
people at all no I do it but I always
look like it is a peck I mean when I
wear these and we've had a couple days
where it's hotter in the studio you get
sweaty in the ears I cannot imagine
wearing this while working working no it
would be miserable it would be
absolutely miserable all right speaking
of miserable that's a great segue you
were on the view this week we covered on
the website when we first went and
grabbed the video it only had a few
couple thousand plays like this is
something everyone's going to want to
see I want to toss to a clip here and
then ask you your thoughts we have that
queued up okay here's a I've been to our
country's promise I've given give me
your tired your weak and your before but
as it turns out about 80 90 percent of
those don't have a valid asylum claim
once we actually get their documentation
is what they've learned over the years
is they need only to raise their hand
and say they're claiming asylum and that
they need a child with them it has dual
talent of homeland security and these
are the numbers that are coming out I
was on the border for one day
and in the Rio Grande Valley they had 14
kids that were identified as not as
being with adults who are not their
parents I thought this was a formidable
performance I encourage people to go
watch the entire interview the entire
segment in its context let me ask you
this so what was the experience like and
what did you expect
or I guess what did you expect to gain
going on the view not I I think it's a
great thing that you you do but some
conservatives think it's a lost cause I
go on shows like that oh it's definitely
not a lost cause and and you do this all
the time you're always on college
campuses you're always putting yourself
in uncomfortable positions and
politicians have to start doing the same
thing and now I'm not the only
politician to gone on Mike Lee went on
recently Steve Scalise went on right you
know and and what happened was exactly
what I
expected that I think they're there they
are they are respectful in the sense
that they stick to the issues that they
said they would stick to I knew I was
going in for for a more combative
conversation but but that's the points
right like you can't just be on Fox News
all the time you can't just stick to
your Republican clubs you got to go to
college campuses I'm sorry I've started
doing that a lot more recently too is
that ASU not too long ago we're gonna
start doing more college campus tours
throughout Texas and you've got to speak
to a different audience right and you're
not gonna convince all of them the ones
who already don't like you are still not
going to like you that's fine but maybe
some will be persuaded and maybe some
who really didn't have an opinion and
now they do and and hopefully it's a
good one and so you got to stand your
ground but but do it in a respectful way
and that was that was our whole goal do
you find that it's tough to express the
whole idea could for example behind camp
like we've done debates on this show and
obviously have gone on I mean every
Network actually not named MSNBC at some
point sometimes I've never been invited
back but do you find and I think that
the idea and changed my mind was to
remove the constraints of a network show
or cable news where we go let's not edit
it either mine or their responses do you
find it hard to make a convincing
argument within those constraints of
traditional media and a commercial break
because what I saw was you talking about
the illegal border crossings no a
hundred thousand last month and how
Border Patrol agents I think you said I
think the number you said it was they
say one they maybe catch one and three
and Sonny just saying no that's not true
and not presenting any evidence or
numbers of our own you don't have enough
time to call her on it I mean you just
kind of have to move on well that is a
constraint and it's just something you
have to deal with as you know when
you're on these you know very quick
segments and I think that's why
Americans by the way are so much more
enthralled by these long-form
conversations that's why people are
downloading podcasts more they want to
listen to people talk for an hour or two
hours they want to see a more drawn-out
debate and there's there's a real hunger
for that and which i think is a it's a
good sign it's a good sign that people
are more interested in that but it's a
constraint we have when we're on TV and
you've just got to anticipate the
arguments so that you could quickly hit
them back right right and I think when
she said that I simply said well you
have no evidence for the Hat
right I just called her on it right
there because she did it I mean it and
if you do show it to me you know and
this is this is a problem with the
immigration debate and in particular
when I'm debating with somebody on the
Left they simply say well I don't
believe your numbers well okay well what
would you believe and what do you think
is happening I mean why would I lie to
you about this but you know that's
that's a that's a kind of a cheap shot
right right but again it's particularly
a cheap shot I don't present anything
themselves like if someone says well hon
a second for example you're taking these
numbers here yeah I've heard people talk
about climate science I'm thinking these
decades you're not you're not picking
these decades if you widen this graph
you look at a different financial
outlook I understand that you can
manipulate statistics os fiver if they
present nothing to say wrong I'm not
trying to convince her in that moment I
I'm hoping that people at home are
watching and say wait a second she
didn't actually she just called you a
liar but she didn't actually say why
right you know that that's what I'm
hoping and that that's why you go on
these shows because I'm speaking to a
non FoxNews audience and and they're
Americans too and we got to talk to them
and I bet a lot more of them would agree
with us if we just spoke to them yeah
that's true no it's the non FoxNews
audiences sometimes referred to as not
80 year olds named Ethel so that's often
the case it really is true that meets
the median conservative demo on
traditional outlets used to be really
old and now with podcasts you know
that's why they're trying to change
social media they're trying to D because
the demographics going younger
generation Z it skipped Millennials are
becoming more conservative speaking of
social media you um you you on Twitter
we're speaking about representative
Brian Simms we tweeted about this a
story went everywhere where he was
effectively harassing elderly well at
least one elderly woman outside of
planned parenting people see the whole
clip and you tweeted that it was I want
to show you this right that a great
example of how to teach young men not to
act now back on the view you talked
about criticizing ideas as opposed to
insulting people in today's political
dialogue and I agree but let me also say
I mean you really called Simms character
into question here which I don't think
is out of line how do you decide when
that's appropriate and how did if
differentiate that kind of a soul sort
of criticism
versus an insult because that was pretty
I mean pretty rough I still I don't
think that was an insult if I if I had
said that's a good question and the way
I would differentiate it was I was
actually still attacking his actions yes
so this is how not saying this is how
not to act this is a great example of
how not to act I didn't say I didn't say
this is a great example of who not to be
mm-hmm
you know yeah I didn't say that he's not
manly even though his actions were very
much not manly you know I mean to God
what he did is just I'm so glad that
this blew up all over the media
and well conservative media I have still
haven't seen it on the news
unfortunately but if you'd have done
some if you'd have tried to Doc's women
oh my gosh yeah of course of course I
mean it's not even a question and the
way he did it was just so vicious and an
unrelenting you know trying to Doc's
underage girls that's that's terrible
and the way just harassed this old lady
for for eight full minutes I mean like
what are you thinking it and I brought
that up you know this is what now not to
teach your young boys to act because you
know I think a lot of us would agree
that there is there is a cultural trend
towards where we're not teaching young
boys how to act whether it's with
respecting women are respecting your
elders or whatever the case is and this
is this is this is a consequence of
losing sight of traditional values and
more generally speaking this is a
consequence of attacking chivalry you
know in your more liberal circles are
gonna say we don't hold the door open
for me I can we will say that right
also Dubai but yes what what do you what
do you what are you creating when you
attack these kind of values I mean
you're you're creating a moment like
this where where it's okay for this this
guy Brian Simms to go up and entreat
people like that just because they have
a different idea or they disagree with
him on something I mean it was just such
a vicious video it was really wish it
was incredibly vicious and I would not
only say unmanly I would say the action
came across as baby where do you live
where do you live where do you live who
what's your name where do you live we're
like repeated I'm gonna like that just
really seems like I'm sorry big hi
schoolgirl who's trying to humiliate
somebody his is fanatical you know he's
so he's captive to his emotions in such
an extreme way that he just he can't
control it and that's really it was
really obvious in that video he could
not control his emotions the way he was
attacking these women and because he's
so set and he's so convinced of his
righteousness right and it's it's it's
it's really problematic and I and I
think a lot of conservatives see that
we're like that's it's something we deal
with quite often where we're dealing
with another side that that uh seems a
little unhinged sometimes and that was
tonight I do think was our state Rep the
fact that it was a representative yes
especially why I I would I wouldn't have
commented it on it otherwise it's very
scary that this man that he was elected
at all and like he said I'd not only do
I think if you're a Republican but let's
let's be honest your mug shots not gonna
make a lot of friends with people who
don't like you already there's this man
harassed a woman who's gonna show a
picture oh my God look at that cleft in
the eye what is he what is this monster
you're not gonna get a lot of grace I'm
saying I'm just just shooting clothes
nobody should get any grace for that you
know it's just that's terrible all right
finally and then if we actually would
like to go to a web extended really
quick after this for people who are
Muslim members but final question before
we go to that House Judiciary just this
week voted to move ahead and holding bar
in contempt of Congress refusing to show
up to yet another hearing before we go
your thoughts on that yeah there's a lot
okay so first of all they're asking him
to show up and be questioned by lawyers
not representatives of the people right
which was which was problematic to begin
with and I don't see a problem with him
saying no I'm not coming and also I
think we all have a pretty good idea of
the circus that the Democrats are trying
to put him through at this point the
contempt issue is also regarding his
unwillingness to to release the fully
unredacted report which they know Emma
Kratz know is perfectly illegal because
of the grand jury testimony necessary in
their bar has offered
I'm about between I think it's 98.5%
unredacted 99.9% sure unredacted in
volume 2 which is all the obstruction of
justice which is what they really want
he's offered them that they refuse to
see it so this is this is this is a
total charade it really is they know me
employers for American people because
it's hard to keep track of this just
like the Russia story ya know that
that's the point they know it's hard to
keep track of they know it's confusing
and they're trying to win the war of
confusion and if it's a really dishonest
way to battle III agree so let me kind
of to distill this for people who don't
necessarily know you know they've said
we're in a constitutional crisis is it a
right of of Congress or is it a right
for these first off is it a right of
Congress to see a fully unredacted
report completely in other words is
there a constitutional crisis and a lack
of transparency there and is bar legally
required to show up to another hearing
before lawyers know neither because this
is this was a investigation done by the
executive branch they don't have to
share it remember Congress has the right
to do its own investigation
right so the Democrats can still do that
and they can waste in it and they can go
through wasting all the resources they
want to do the exact investigations and
that so that's where the balance of
power actually comes into play and you
know they can hold bar in contempt all
they want he's of course under no real
obligation so right well I think it's
just important to clarify for people
because ago a lot of people say well he
has to show up no he doesn't well he has
to release the full report it's illegal
no it's not and when you frame it that
way you go huh okay maybe I should look
into what's been confusing me a little
bit because yeah I'd say we do have a
constitutional crisis if those things
were illegal or legally required all
right if you can hold on for another
couple minutes that is representative
Dan Crenshaw second District of Texas
Dan Crenshaw TX on Twitter we're going
to go quick web extended from when his
mug club because I keep
[Music]
delicious as these unwitting imps
fulfill what they believed to be their
destiny
they will soon realize that they have
merely been fulfilling their rules as
all Oh puppets and I is their puppeteer
mclubbe shall be mine oh yes it shall be
mine
[Music]
one live read of the week I bet you
expected me to plug mud club bladders
credit calm slash mud Club where you'll
also have some exclusive content with
Dan Crenshaw on the hodgetwins this week
along with the daily show but you
already know about that and if you
haven't joined already with the deep
platforming you'll never join there's no
way to support this show wealth or
firearms have the balls to sponsor this
show and we are eternally grateful to
them they've stood by us through all the
controversies I really haven't been that
bad let's be honest um and I know they
have a lot of choices for firearms out
there you have uh like I don't know if I
can name them Brand X they're all good
here's the truth I'm not going to lie to
you and sell you something you don't
need I particularly prefer the Walther I
always have I went to them to become a
sponsor not the other way around and uh
at a certain point you just have to
decide on personal preference and who
you want to support so Walter firearms
just go to the range and try it they're
fun smooth triggers extremely reliable
these babies basically sell themselves
I'm just goofing it along a little bit
are you ready there hey kids
join my club and loaders powder dot-com
slash mug Club ninety-nine dollars
annually 69 for students veterans our
active military you don't need a promo
code anymore you just Chuck a bar
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
that was called the person who is more
concerned about the SPF on his chapstick
than he is drowning and so he drowned
actually almost happened to me in
Florida so on say if my wife made me
wear this weird Chet SPF chapstick and
when I got in the pool started coming
off and actually was I think what is
that what is this weird thing on my lips
and I was underwater forgot you were and
I forgot to breathe yeah just your
preferred host ladies and gentlemen no
vision because I put very little of
myself incredible gel I almost forgot I
almost died because I forgot to breathe
accidentally think about that for a
second I have no business being on this
platform thank you so much for presenter
Dan Crenshaw I mean it was obvious way
to pre-tape because he was a busy man
this week so there is that extended
version of course for those who are
listen we're not gonna pitch you on it
it just means you don't want to use a
contour anymore um I wanted to talk
about something here today you know I
was talking with someone the other day
and I realize this is always a grave
ated me and I kind of knew why but I
hadn't articulated why and then it came
up again how often do we hear this old
someone someone describe somebody like
oh he's really nice yeah second how is
this what do you think of this guy mean
oh you know I guess he's a nice guy
and I've heard that a lot I heard
recently someone who had a daughter is
telling well you know I think if she
didn't he seems like a nice guy who
gives a rat's ass this is all right it's
something that's always bothered me sure
listen don't get me wrong here before I
move on it's obviously good to be polite
to be respectful okay but we place far
too great of an importance on nice don't
let nice be your guiding light don't let
nice be your litmus test if you make
nice your primary value and I know
ironically it sounds nice to do it makes
you sound like a nice person if you make
nice your primary value it can render
the rest of your values completely
meaningless because guess what at some
point you are going to if you're a
person of conviction you will have to
unkindly defend your values you will
have to unkindly stand for something now
of course I want to make it really clear
here I'm not saying that all nice people
cowards that is not what I'm saying at
all I'm not saying you should be mean
let me just let you in on something I
think everyone knows this who's been
actually betrayed in their life or who
has had something happen with different
betrayal requires nice true deception
requires nice the devil you need to
worry about isn't one who shows up with
a creaky coffin in a pitchfork it's the
sweet talker it's the charmer it's the
one who can give you everything you want
or the one even just provides a little
bit of relief just eases your discomfort
a little bit basically a nice guy in
just as certainly the flaws that you
mean we've talked about this a lot on
this show trying to correct ourselves
trying to work toward self-improvement
the flaws that you may look for within
yourself they're not often going to show
up as festering sore sometimes they show
up as pretty bows that you wear to cover
them up and none of this is to say that
you should not be nice be nice is a good
thing everyone important that I would
say being respectful than being nice
meanness for meanness sake just as
surely is evil don't get me wrong my
point is that as a society we really do
place far too great of an emphasis on
nice we often give it when you think
about it first billing and how we
describe people ideas even scarier and
how we judge them often the people who
say don't be judgmental are the people
who judge people whether they're nice or
not and my point here is that nice can a
lie nice can deceive nice can be wrong
of course
so can anger but guess what truth can't
give me some example socialism past
office nice but it's wrong Osama bin
Laden in particular was apparently very
nice to children but he was wrong and
that's why I've always said I don't
believe in political centrism or middle
ground for political centers I'm safe
because because look we found common
ground oh well that's nice but was the
truth found there on that common girl
let me make it a little less extreme
because I know you're thinking socialism
Osama bin Laden all right
everyone knows somebody like this think
of someone your life I don't your buddy
who's the nicest guy in the world never
raised his voice had a conflict in his
life it could be him or her okay we all
know someone got that person in your
mind he's wrong because side things this
is
here and I know this may sound like
again I'm saying not to be nice some
things in life are worth fighting for
and fighting by its very definition is
not nice and sometimes we use the
disproportionate value that our world
places on nice to advocator
responsibilities to avoid what we know
is worth fighting for or to avoid even
looking at what is worth fighting for in
the first place
and because the the fight even though it
may be righteous we know is going to
piss some people off and that's not fun
that's hard
no one ever blew a gasket at someone for
being too nice I understand that that
doesn't mean that it's right and this is
something that's I think probably Jordan
Peterson has talked about this quite a
bit it's important to be a good person
it's important to be a well-rounded
person just as it's important to be
physically healthy as it is to be
mentally healthy and spiritually healthy
it's important to learn to be polite to
learn to be respectful and to learn to
socialize with others but just as
important and something we don't often
talk about is to learn how to fight to
learn when to fight to learn when
conflict is appropriate to learn when
the value of nice should be trumped by
the value of actually standing by your
conviction so the next time you think
about someone this is my challenge you
this week we all judge people so if you
want to come in and say I don't judge
folks yeah you do you do judge people I
judge people everyone makes judgments
the next time you pass judgment on an
idea on a person this week I want you to
stop yourself and say hold on a second
am I thinking is my first value here
whether they're nice or not are you
looking for what they stand for
well that's I'm token are you looking at
your own ideas and your own actions and
are you saying am i a nice person or am
i a righteous person am i doing the
right thing if I could change nothing
else this week would be that at least
even just a few dozen of you go out
there and place a different importance a
different level of priority on following
believing living out your principles
fighting for them when appropriate and
then let's have nice somewhere toward
the middle of the pack that's it you
don't need to eliminate any of them
let's just shuffle up the leaderboard a
little bit okay I'll see you next week
thanks for listening watching wherever
you want
[Music]